violent à côté d'elle enfin c'est
remarquable parce qu'en fait elle fait
rien les bras
au mieux les dénoncer manette pas mais
là les chats je suis pas là dedans
regardez regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
quand une équipe dix familles alors
c'est l'anniversaire de l'un de nous est
bas c'est la fête c'est vrai mais il y
en a une autre qui fêtait son
anniversaire c'est erika moulet on m'a
dit vous verrez que vous mettiez votre
34 ans ce que n'a pas un mec de l'équipe
kita
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien vous allez vous eric assez
particulier on l'aiment bien amoché la
mena mais on la comprend pas toujours
mais parfois il part dans des
explications lunaire on n'arrive pas à
suivre
là vous allez voir sans raison
particulière et nous parler de sa soirée
dans un escape game
regardez la corniche basque il était dur
on en passe tout le monde est magique
mais mon préféré c'est gilles verdez lui
il est carrément paniqué j'ai fini 7e
hier c'est génial et ça me fait penser à
ça c'est à dire qu'on tend vers la
culture de julie et je vous emmerde à
cirer cintres de fous vous attend une
pièce vous avez vous avez 60 minutes
[Applaudissements]
les sages du fouta le garagiste du
soutien mais j'en remets petit quelque
chose
il est tour à tour plus ils étaient même
c'est bon là qu'on l'ait mal à halen
singularité comme tous ici d'ailleurs
voilà vous avez tous une singularité
attend plus que d'autres voilà oui mais
c'est normal il faut s'habituer
titi et jean-michel par exemple ça fait
longtemps qu'ils se connaissent donc ils
sont très complices presque trop non
mais franchement je regardais un petit
peu dans le rétroviseur ils ont beaucoup
évolué depuis le début de touche pas à
mon poste là pour un débat on avait
distribué des pancartes avec des têtes
de présentateurs de jt
non
[Musique]
je
ouais quand même et salades et on avoue
des temps quand on voit ça on aimerait
bien que jean-michel repas de couvrir un
conflit quand même personne et brion
ensuite la meilleure intervention de
jean michel du mois complet a fallu plus
[Applaudissements]
à lui ce dernier salue ce pas lui après
ils s'étonnent que je montre voilages
expliquant même cyril parler latin et
demander les mots que les chroniqueurs
cause de caunes et c'est ce qui nous a
mené à cette belle réflexion de notre
champion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de stéphane bern présenté par
jean-michel baer a baissé mes secrets
d'histoire
je pense qu'on a perdu des impôts si
mais tu sais pas pourquoi c'est aussi un
esprit de cohésion jeu facile vous
souvenez de l'émission spéciale koh
lanta et bas lors de cette édition il y
avait deux équipes
aouita nas lra sera os et à la pose de
producteurs nourdine était venu voir
chaque équipe pour leur demander de
trouver un cri de guerre
je vais pas laisser ce top10 de volonté
ce brillant
[Rires]
[Musique]
ce pack est plus fort à la main nous
police et aux raisons d'avoir le bonheur
expansif parce que une minute plus tard
c'est ce que je me dis c'est toute là
zone aurait dans las
[Applaudissements]
on est on est là-bas trail ou non vous
êtes l'état lâche alors cela dans
d'autres ça va les y voilà
et l'autre ne l'obtiennent se démonta
n'ont jamais joué pour moi je les vois
dépité je sais pas pourquoi je dis voilà
j'en reviens la place tranquille ses
rayonnages me dit mon nom je leur dis
non et en fêtard oui vous avez bien
possible et très déçu ce côté là bon
après je vous refais pas toutes les
missions mais à un moment d'état nas ont
dû éliminer des rats sera et bien comme
c'est le prime de la vérité je dois te
dire si et n'aura été sauvés bah c'est
grâce à mathieu présidente au conseil de
koh lanta il ya une tension c'est le
voyage au regard de la maine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il ya bien d'ailleurs réservé doit voir
un gars de l'année ce qui va avoir un
effet pour en fait je suis juste cette
scène ce que j'ai dit en garde l'année
vous défendez pas d'armé et n'aura il
vous a sauvé parce qu'il vous aime
on s'en fout de la taille des gens
importants c'est le talent la raison il
dit il a raison mathieu aime beaucoup et
n'aura alors quand il s'agit de définir
notre pile but breton
celui qui en parle le mieux est basse et
mathieu à la honte de le dire tu es
dépendante de conneries mais ça va aller
dont kaunas non mais moi il m'a engueulé
parce que j'étais un homme banon mais
bon quand même pas de ma faute si
l'intrus samedi en suisse
[Musique]
[Rires]
pas possible
là vous l'adorez impôts d origine adore
mais c'est que c'est un pote
voilà c'est ça un poteau avec des
nichons bon ça c'était l'époque où
mathieu n'était pas encore capricieux et
wiz essayez là où on disait de s'asseoir
à maintenant c'est fini
s'il n'a pas sa place il boude regardez
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
nouveau
et c'est nouveau ce petit effet lundi
il faut savoir la place de mathieu c'est
là à côté de valérie bénaïm et ça pour
valérie ses plus gros coup dur parce que
mathieu comment dire il est gentil il
comprend tout très vite mais il faut lui
expliquer longtemps
par exemple depuis le début de l'année
il perçoit que valérie et arabes maroc
obligatoirement elle a dû investir dans
un restaurant de couscous pour ovi com
est une idée en tête j'allais les voir
au bout d'un moment même si c'est très
difficile de le faire sortir de ses
gonds on sent que valérie on a vraiment
ras le bol
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est prêt
m
[Musique]
absolument
en suisse
fusion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour que vous sachiez merguez
boulette tout ça c'est là là ça n'a rien
à voir c'est hachis parmentier voilà
qu'en cauvin et là tout ça d'accord de
là vous avez vous êtes entre les deux
d'accord vous êtes entre la merguez et
le pois chiche ça prouve à mon jeune
pays va y avait toujours dans les
rapports entre chroniqueurs il faut
savoir que dans l'équipe on a un avis
très arrêtées sur le physique de ses
collègues
[Musique]
et on a un physique comme on est gentil
avec cela
merci
bon sens lui qui dès aujourd'hui il ya
d'autres choses qui arrivent à temps
plein de choses et vous aurez et des
normes régression suis même pas de quoi
il s'agit
ça sera dans la deuxième partie mais
énorme alors vraiment ah ouais je vous
avais dit surpris et jolie et ya gilles
verdez on a une surprise pour lui et
vous a préparé quelque chose parce que
vous allez voir une surprise pour vous
et vous verrez il y aura le frère de
gilles bérard à nous voir peindre un
instant sur d8 et ils ont préparé un
numéro avec des poils et le frère de
gilles verdez vous le connaissez pas
tout de suite sur des huit suites des
cafetières
[Applaudissements]